India has the world's second largest
population and is one of the fastest
growing economies today experts predict
that India will become a global
superpower within 50 years thanks to its
economic growth and young population
despite this India remains one of the
poorest countries with a 35-percent
illiteracy rate access to healthcare
reliable power and clean water are also
in desperate short supply could these
gaps prevent India from achieving what
finally seems within its grasp we want
to know what you think can India become
a superpower vote now in our poll upload
a video reply and tell us what it takes
to make India a superpower the best
videos will be shown during the World
Economic Forum's in the economic summit
in November